por paus pessoal do inter é mais um
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
tantã uma bazuca basicamente pronto não
parece mas eu fiz a bazuca só com o
vídeo ficou curto eu saiba ele chama de
ensinar uma coronha esse vídeo vai ficar
ligeiramente melhor e vai dar duas
opções de escolha pra vocês não querem
fazer uso que o querem fazer de vestir o
shopping game essa idéia aí pra fazer
isso precisar de um cano o cano vai
depender do vosso gosto muito do que
vocês quiserem fazer se quiserem fazer
uma casa dela vai ser um cano com
diâmetro menor
se vocês quiserem fazer uma bazuca tem
que ser um diâmetro maior podem usar
aquelas latas pneus ok é isso você usar
em um campo muito grande tem que usar
mais elástico
neste caso estou usar elástico o
escritório para variar um pouco mas se
vocês tiverem que o elástico costureira
fica muito melhor e vai ficar muito mais
tempo aqui e depois vão precisar de um
docinho dá uma coisa de madeira que irá
usar porque o time de picolé disputada
na espanha tve qual é mas se vocês não
tiverem salvar um precinho um ramo e ea
gente gosta de moto ficou parecido com
isso aqui é só estar usando o fio usar
bancos mas vocês podem usar outro
qualquer e isso não vale de nada vocês
vão se perguntar eu acho que usar
hospital é não interessa é importante
que seja resistente e não estique fazem
um nó e deixa uma pequena distância
entre a quarta do palito e um nó que
vocês deram com um elástico
depois é só passar todo um lado a outro
o chão e vejam como é que se carregue a
arma é só empurrar da south park e
pronto vocês quiserem fazer aquilo que
quer salvar um quibe e cortar em uma das
partes vai parecer muito fácil mas não é
assim tão fácil mourão queria cair por 1
minuto a custar isso é com essas é ruim
aí é só colar na cola quente mas podem
usar outra coisa qualquer item bastante
opcional neste caso
nos outros casos às vezes não costuma se
estiver tudo vai só você tirar daqui
para fora o ps madeira esticão um fio e
prendem isto porque para pois vocês
conseguirem enxergar facilmente a água
aqui como é que querem tirar aquela
dessa maneira para fora encaixam pois
metem o celular para dentro pra não
ficar assim tipo as turvaram aqui para
não prender um de vós acidentalmente que
vai alojar mais para ficar sem treinar
só chegamos ao fim e os pés amputados
vocês tiverem alguma substância porchat
é só deixar os comentários se vocês
quiserem dar o pênalti achei um like se
inscreva para acompanhar as coisas que
eu faço é isso então pronto só muito
obrigado que tchau